hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and you know it's been a while
since I've posted a video you know but
to be honest it's coming on the end of
the year and we are making a lot of
strides in um improving the order flows
Trader for 2024 you know we got an
update plann for um first quarter of
2024 but one of the things that I've
really been excited about that I've been
working on is the order flows trade
setup encyclopedia and what it is it's
128 orderflow trade setups that I've
taught Traders over the years Now to
create this massive orderflow trade
encyclopedia I went through all my
trading courses workshops mentoring
sessions pulled out the trade setups and
put them in this collection right and
really the the reason for doing that is
you know nowadays you know a lot of
Traders already understand they have a
grasp of orderflow analysis right they
understand Delta they understand point
of control they understand um imbalances
and you know now they're at the point of
just tell me what to look for okay and
that's why I grabbed all these trade
setups my various courses uh group
trainings you know even um private
workshops Etc and put them in this
collection so imagine what a difference
just learning a few of these setups can
make to your trading right because you
know even though it's 128 setups I don't
expect you to understand all of them or
use all of them really what you want to
do is you want to take the handful that
resonate with you that Mak sense to you
that help you understand what you're
looking at in the market and use those
and I know from experience that some of
these setups have transformed Traders
from break even into successful
consistent Traders now just you know a
brief overview on some of the courses
that I've created over the last you know
eight nine years you know the order
flows Playbook um the Alchemy course
situational order flow order flow
Dynamics Next Level order flow even
Advanced orderflow trading as well as
individual courses on things like
absorption imbalances uh Delta point of
control momentum and reversal as well as
um my private workshops my private group
training
basically what I've done is I've taken
all those trade setups and I've put them
in this one Magnus Opus as I call it of
128 meticulously curated trade setups
each centered around different aspects
of orderflow analysis whether it's a
Delta point of control and imbalance or
just interpreting orderflow volumes
right I leave no stone unturned it's
time you elevate your trading game and
make informed decisions that's going to
lead to success now the orderflow trade
encyclopedia has broken down into four
sect
the general orderflow trade setups of
which there's actually two subsections
because there's 50 setups there so you
know not to make it like overwhelming
for you I've broken it down into part
one and part two there's the Delta
setups of which consist of uh 34 setups
the point of controls which is 22 setups
imbalance which is also uh 22 setups the
general order flow is is 50 there's 735
charts that's explained right I've
created videos explaining explaining all
of these setups now each section has its
own video so there's five videos but
it's over 8 hours of new and fresh
recorded video explanations so I'm not
just taking out the the trade setups
from the previous courses and using the
same videos no I'm giving you a fresh
look sort of a you know a 2023 24 update
on these setups so you're going to
unleash the power of Delta right with 34
Delta trade setups at your disposal
you're going to gain a deep
understanding of Delta and leverage them
to identify hidden trade opportunities
in the market the detailed descriptions
and Analysis tips will Empower you to
spot these setups and make profitable
moves with confidence you're going to
master the point of control right the
point of control is the price level in
the in the bar with the most volume and
it offers invaluable insights into
testing this critical price level so by
understanding the behavior of price
round point of control you're going to
be equipped to make smarter trading
decisions and stay one step ahead of the
market and there's volume and volume
imbalances right you're going to
discover 22 volume imbalance trade
setups that teach you how to recognize
and exploit volume imbalances for
maximum profit potential this
encyclopedia equips you with the
knowledge to anticipate Market movements
and sees the most favorable trading
opportunities and lastly the
comprehensive orderflow expertise you're
going to get from 50 General orderflow
trade setups you're going to gain a
solid foundation in interpreting and
analyzing orderflow data these setups
cover a wide range of orderflow
behaviors ensuring that you have
comprehensive understanding of this
essential trading aspect so just a brief
look inside right you're going to see
there's five videos there's the general
orderflow trade setup section part one
part two you can download the videos you
can watch them you know from your
computer as well but you could download
them to your you know your phone your
iPad your computer as well as the
PDFs with all the charts and explanation
of the trade setup and there's so you
have that for the general orderflow
trade setups part one and part two the
Delta section the point of control
section and the imbalance section so not
only do you get access to the videos but
you can also download each video and the
PDFs with the setup explanation and
charts you know you can watch them
whenever you want print up the PDFs and
put them in their own binder now I just
want to tell you there are 913 pages
that includes the charts so you're going
to need uh probably a couple binders or
you know one big gigantic 5in binder
so the link to get started is in the
description there is a cost for this
it's a really low cost but again you
know I just want to get this information
out there to everybody I do believe that
orderflow is the way to trade but if
you're interested check out the
description below and I'll see you guys
on the
inside